[Music]
every Disney princess has her strengths
but when it comes to Moana many of us
would agree that she's got everything in
the bag despite her movie ending on a
good note we're still left wondering
whether or not she got her happily ever
after
want to know what Moana has been up to
well you've come to the right place
watch until the end to find out if the
princess will be wearing a wedding dress
anytime soon new around here don't
forget to subscribe to the things for
more amazing content to come your way if
you love Moana as much as we do you
won't hesitate to give this video a big
thumbs up now let's find out if Moana
got the happily ever after she deserved
fewer fair Maui see you out there
Moana she's claiming new islands as many
of you know Moana spent most of her life
fearing the ocean but as she grew older
her curiosity got the best of her
before long she began dreaming of the
world beyond the reef which led her to
disregard her father's warnings despite
wanting to become a master wayfinder
Moana stayed true to her calling and
learned how to become a proper ruler
however it soon became apparent that her
island was sick which forced her to
embark on the biggest adventure of her
life after reuniting taffy tea with her
long-lost heart
mallanna's life changed for the better
and so did the lives of her people at
the end of Moana you can see the young
princess guiding her people through the
ocean and teaching them how to sail it's
here that it becomes evident that Moana
will never stay put again instead she'll
help her people find new islands to
populate and care for since travel and
adventure are in her blood it's only
normal for the young princess to dream
of chasing the horizon while the
daughter of the chief has a job to do
she never lets this stop her from
traveling across the oceanic all in all
there isn't a person in this world who
could stop Moana from her true calling
which is being the best master Wayfinder
Mota Nui has ever seen she's befriended
other princesses it's hard to picture
Moana being anywhere else but on a
sailboat but it looks like the young
princess has strayed a little far from
home wreck-it Ralph too is set to come
out in theaters in November 21st 2018
and believe it or not but Moana will be
making an appearance in the highly
anticipated film so
what is moana doing at the disney/pixar
headquarters well it's quite simple
she's getting to know her fellow
princesses from what we gather it looks
like the Disney Princesses are getting
together for a sleepover party and Moana
looks more than happy to be a part of it
despite each having a kingdom to go back
to these princesses are more than happy
to kick back relax and talk about the
hardships they've been through when
vanellope von schweetz glitches herself
through their restricted doors she
appears in the middle of the princesses
headquarters and is quickly ambushed by
the 14 Disney figures before getting the
royal beating of her life though she
confesses to being a princess herself
after grilling her with a handful of
questions Penelope find some common
ground with her house and after agreeing
that people think that all her problems
were solved after a big strong man
showed up the princesses cut her some
slack
although Moana doesn't say much
throughout the scenes it's pretty
obvious that she's living life to the
fullest she's the new chief Moana is the
daughter of chief tui and Sina however
she's a little different than her
parents while our parents Harbor a great
fear of the ocean their daughter dreams
of being surrounded by weights for days
despite being raised on the notion that
her people do not belong in the sea
Moana is soon given the task of
reuniting taffy T with her heart after a
long and action-packed journey Moana
returns to mota nui to find that her
island's beauty has been restored
knowing that his daughter has what it
takes to lead his people cheap to eat
passes his title down to his only child
instead of upholding her father's rules
Moana teaches her people to become
master way finders like herself with her
newfound sense of freedom
chief Moana reunites her people with her
old roots which is what her ancestors
would have wanted despite the way she
was raised shall never allow fear to
rule her judgment again instead she
teaches others about the importance of
going after their dreams at the end of
the film we see her father and daughter
sealing side by side and this unexpected
moment goes on to prove that anything is
possible if you just believe she's
working on her second movie with the way
things ended in Moana you would think
that there was no room for a sequel but
it seems as though Disney has other
plans for their oceanic princess after
becoming the chief of her people
Moana becomes a
much loved leader she is kind thoughtful
brave and smart so what's not to love
right despite how well things are going
Moana soon returns to see your old pal
Maui who lets her in on a little secret
after finding out that palm trees are
going extinct from island to island
Moana returns home to find that her
mother has fallen ill so can you guess
which special ingredient her mother
needs to make it out alive
you guessed it coconuts to save her
mother's life Moana sets off on a new
journey that takes her to a places she's
never been the second installment of
this Disney movie should hit the big
screen sometime in 2019 however an exact
date has yet to be set are you excited
to see what Mona's newest adventure has
in store for us well you should be
because a royal wedding might be in
order
watch until the end to find out who
Moana x' knight in shining armor is
she's revealing her true self there's a
lot about Moana that we don't know which
makes her all the more interesting the
brave Disney Princess never backs down
from a fight and she knows just what to
say to make others follow her lead the
Polynesian princess might only be
sixteen years old but she has more than
enough experience to lead her people to
greatness back in the day Disney movies
always ended with a wedding however
times are changing and this is no longer
the case
in fact movies like brave frozen and
Moana have all taken place without
revealing a love interest for their
protagonists since Disney is keeping up
with the times it's only normal for
there to be an LGBTQ princess on the
horizon but Disney has yet to confirm
which one of their princesses will swing
the other way the directors behind the
Moana franchise have spoken out about
their interest in creating a non hetero
relationship for one of their star
players directors Ron Clements and John
Musker are certain that Disney
characters will soon shed their romantic
preferences and merely love whoever it
is they're attracted to
while most fans are inclined to believe
that Elsa or Merida are going to become
a lesbian couple we shouldn't strike
Moana from the equation in the end the
world needs an LGBTQ Disney Princess to
come to life and this could help
millions of people feel more comfortable
about their orientation from the get-go
she's growing her fleet chief Moana
wants the best for her people which is
why she does everything in
power to make them happy and comfortable
unfortunately not every leader is as
accepting and loving as the young
princess while there was little to no
talk of war throughout the Moana movie
some fans were left wondering if the
Moto Nui people had any enemies of their
own to protect her people we believe
that Moana is sailing across the sea to
discover new islands and accumulate more
followers although it's obvious that
Moana wouldn't hurt a fly
there is strength in numbers and safely
guarding her people is her biggest
priority to grow her fleet we believe
that Moana is recruiting builders and
sailors and promising them a place in
her kingdom to raise a new and powerful
generation of wayfinders Moana is surely
sailing across the sea and making new
connections along the way despite having
an incredible friendship with the
demigod Maui Moana was left to navigate
the oceans on her own but thankfully
Maui taught the young leader everything
she needed to know on their first voyage
when I die I'm going to come back or I
chose the wrong Tecton she's protecting
sea life there's nothing more important
than family however without a world to
live in family wouldn't exist with this
in mind Moana knows how crucial it is
for her people to take care of the ocean
and everything that lays in its path
well some people use motor boats to get
around mo honest people strictly use
sailboats which helps keep the beaches
clean if there's one person who taught
Moana about the importance of following
her dreams it's the late grandma Tala mo
Ana's grandmother was always her biggest
supporter and she's the one who let her
in on the ancestors secret grandma Tala
passes away
Milana vows to accomplish her
frightening task luckily for her her
grandmother gets reincarnated into a
manta ray and follows her every step of
the way
knowing that grandma is now a part of
the ocean gives Moana
even more incentive to protect all sea
life she's keeping an eye on Maui from
the very second Moana met Maui she knew
that she had her work cut out for her
despite being the famous demigod
everyone believed him to be Maui also
had a handful of Secrets that he was
keeping to himself with this in mind it
wasn't surprising to see Maui turn his
back on Moana and attempt to sail off
with her boat despite becoming great
and allies the demigod refused to live
on mallanna's island after their epic
journey came to an end but that doesn't
mean that she didn't keep a close eye on
him from afar after all he did steal
tapes CDs heart the first time around
well the plot for Moana to the Lost
Island has yet to be a hundred percent
confirmed it said that Moana and Maui
will reunite once again however this
time Moana will find him on the two Fiji
Islands despite wanting to go on a
second adventure with her old pal
Moana ends up embarking on her own
voyage alone the reason behind Maui not
tagging along is unknown and just a
little suspicious this is especially
true considering the amount of success
actor dwayne johnson brought to the
Disney flick whether good or evil we
hope Maui will be a prominent figure in
the franchise's second installment she
becomes the next to bTW there's no use
denying it mallanna is the spitting
image of taffy tea sure the goddess
might be as tall as a mountain
and as green as the Grinch but she is
basically a mirror image of our favorite
Polynesian princess it is said that
tippy tea was the first entity to step
foot on the planet which could only be
inhabited by sea life at the time to
create a home for humans to feed he gave
birth to islands that flourished with
greenery and animals alight throughout
the film it becomes known that the mana
tui believe in reincarnation so this
left us with one simple question
Wilma wanna reincarnate into the
beautiful and virtuous to Phoebe
while this could seem a little
far-fetched it does make sense so hear
us out when tippy Dee's heart was stolen
from her the ocean elected Moana to
return it this is because she alone had
the kindness and bravery needed to
complete such a voyage so why would the
ocean elect Moana if she didn't have
some sort of special connection with the
goddess
we believe that Moana is either the
descendant of this ancient presence or
that she's meant to take after her once
she passes on to the next life what do
you think about this theory could Moana
and tippy tea be one in the scene she's
getting married but to who back in the
day there was no doubt in our minds that
Disney Princesses would be courted and
Wed by the end of their film however
this just isn't the case anymore if it
had been Moana evidently would have been
married to Maui at the end of their
adventure but luckily she wasn't made
in the end Moana and Maui would be a
strange couple especially since he's
about 2000 years older than her while
getting married at 16 years old used to
be acceptable it no longer is
well there's talk of a second Moana
movie and if its time line follows ours
this will make cheap Moana 19 years old
so who is the princess going to marry
according to many fan theories the
answer is a character named Reacher this
mysterious personality will pose as
Mona's companion throughout her second
journey and if the stars align these two
characters will fall in love so would
you rather see Moana get married stay
single or come out as gay let us know in
the comments section below
and that's the end of our video thanks
for watching and see you next time on
the things
[Music]